it smells funny smells like Sisler's
cheese brand if the Burger Illuminati
exists secret menu burgers are their
objects of worship because when you hold
those keys a whole world of burgers open
their doors today me and my old friend
Seth Rogen yes dudes
Seth pineapple express Rogen are meeting
up in Hollywood to taste some
underground legends in the fast food
game and crown a winner
so my man dude what's up a lot of people
don't know this but like seven years ago
when we met I was I was this bright-eyed
bushy-tailed food truck operator on
Fairfax one night I'm just getting like
out of this world stone and like a
special occasion yes six hours later you
walk up to the truck and you're like ah
bacon egg and cheese and I'm like you're
[ __ ] Seth Rogen dude I just smoked a
blunt to you last night thank you very
much your money's no good here yeah you
didn't charge me ever ever
I tipped I tried to compensate with
typical any story and I don't know if
you ever heard this on our third year of
our food truck we were on our way to an
event and the event would have like
taken care of us for like the whole
month all we had was money in the
register before that event we have our
business license or health license any
legal stuff Health Department fire
department stuff and then an envelope
that said Seth Rogen emergency fund and
it was every single tip that you ever
put I told you I would never take your
money money I'd never spend a dime that
does that I ever crazy
so we shredded our back tire on our food
truck and I needed 350 dollars to get it
fixed
and there was three hundred and eighty
dollars in that end really that's crazy
but because of you
like our last leg on the truck we were
able to keep pushing on it because that
cab that's absolutely that's why the
stars are aligned you're on the burger I
couldn't be happier beer you were parked
outside a coffee place I would go to all
the time right off in Fairfax I remember
I love bacon egg and cheese sandwiches
also alright my favorite [ __ ] in the
entire world
I really guess it's it when you guys
pulled up I was just like oh my god
what's happening no because I you would
come early enough to where you could
park on the street yeah we would see
your black SUV I want some bacon that's
amazing your celebrity so I'm sure
there's a ton of off menu stuff like you
know compliments of the chef like what
do you feel about off menu secret item I
makes me uncomfortable because often
what happens is I'll be at a restaurant
and there'll be other people who are not
famous normal people I call them normies
they'll be non famous people's guys
beside us
I know and they'll see us them coming up
to us oh here drives off the menu and
more than dozens of times I see the
people be like what's that right then I
awkwardly see the big suede like oh
sorry like he's better than you are and
it makes me feel like good take it it's
a flex but when it comes to like burgers
like in and out obviously Shake Shack
has one and then you know five guys has
one why do they do that I don't get like
is there a burger Illuminati like if
there is I want in let's try these off
menu item to Swan Yates yeah and let's
see which one you like best let's try
some frilly [ __ ] we have the
double-double from hitting out and
animal style I've gotten in full-on
arguments with people like what the [ __ ]
animal style is exactly well in its
purest form
yeah it's patties riddled with mustard
chopped onions pickles loaded with
spread usually it comes with lettuce and
tomato I said no it's not tomato season
no ma'am
this one I had them kick it up and it's
whole grilled onions which is takes
another [ __ ] five minutes in your way
time
and then chopped chilies that's like my
and even though they had been chopped
chilies this is a way to go they got
like a bin full of chilies only if
[ __ ] asked for it yeah
[Music]
if you don't order double-double animal
style chopped chilies you haven't had an
animal show double-double you just
haven't had it once I got food poisoning
from in-n-out burger
whoa like hands down [ __ ] straight-up
food poisoning how much I like in that
burger I was back at it within a week
that goes for me and every taco place I
go and there's other yeah there's other
[ __ ] I've gotten food poisoning from
that I haven't touched in like a [ __ ]
decade ended up or [ __ ] up way worse
and still within a few days I like yeah
why is the nut burger so [ __ ] tasty
hey the thin patties right love thin
patties in patties are for [ __ ]
you're overcompensating money you should
be eating a steak they like to flip
their top bun yeah I'm in a toast right
here yeah so it's like soft crunchy
meaty crunchy soft yeah it's just so
perfectly articulated burger this
[ __ ] pepper thing is a revelation and
I feel like I've been living a fools
life in the dark for the last [ __ ] 20
years we just had the Tupac burger yeah
you know West Coast now we're going to
the biggie New York
Shake Shack there is rivalry it's not
your shirt it's like deep I've got a
dreaming argument oh yeah like I did
this thing where I last season I mix the
an in-and-out burger with and Shake
Shack burger I made one burger that's
beautiful and people are like dude you
can't [ __ ] do that oh I think that
would be so nice so in parallel they
also have a secret burger menu yeah item
and it's a bacon burger you have like a
gourmet blend got LaFrieda does it then
they have the Martin's potato roll which
is like God's gift to Burger world with
a side of peanut butter sauce it's
inspired by the goober burger in
of course as one is yeah let's throw
some of this peanut butter on there this
this is sounds like a dish that like in
a 1980s movie a pregnant woman would
order yeah or if you know I'm taking a
[ __ ] real serious bong hit Shake
Shack secret burger it's messy yeah it's
weird
you both do things like peanut butter
peanut butter is overpower yeah I don't
think I'd order it it tastes exactly
like I didn't think it would take you
know Elvis Presley hate [ __ ] like this
and that's why you died well you [ __ ]
your insides out I live in New York now
and I have a dog there dog treats
how peanut butter peanut butter is this
peanut butter from there no I want to
find out keep your secrets to yourself
Shake Shack that could just stay as a
secret less is the five guys secret menu
item and it has this is [ __ ] crazy
it's a grilled cheese top bun grilled
cheese bottom bun two patties and cheese
I've made something similar this as a
stunt burger
you have to stunt yeah joke yeah this is
a stunt burger you'll give this to
someone you like tastes excessive it's a
little dry it smells funny
smells like Sisler's cheese brand all
right it does no it has a cheese bread
yeah weird i but i would eat the [ __ ]
out of this no time to place two in the
morning and you know you don't want to
eat though
but like he just got high no you're
debating whether or not the worst I can
either just keep snacking or just fall
asleep after I could just nuke myself
like the peanut butter is like it's
almost like a [ __ ] you gimmick maybe you
put some peanut butter on your burger
dick this is like it's gimmicky but it
feels like good serving a purpose in
some way and if you don't have a lot of
money you can buy one and then parse it
out you make several meals out of this
you don't want beef here's real cheese
your grilled cheese a lounge at first
glance it looks like they got two slices
of like white bread oh-ho but really
what it is is it's a burger bun that's
inverted Oh weird so they do you know
that this is created by a line cook
who's baked out of his [ __ ] out of
his [ __ ] mind I bless these people
this is an expression of someone's which
I like about it yeah unlike the little
thing of dog peanut butter dog peanut
butter because I can't say how much I
like shake check no disrespect [ __ ]
[ __ ] don't do it yes don't have one
[Music]
so we have had all three we have in and
out double-double peanut butter shake
shack double grilled cheese burger from
five guys each with their merits I would
eliminate the shake-shake is
automatically out of the picture out of
here that's not that's not I don't want
that we actually had two pretty good
burgers
yeah pound for pound I believe they're
in different leagues I agree you know
because I feel also like the five guys
one although great it's kind of like a
gimmick five guys has always been like a
sleeper for me yeah yeah yeah like they
never get there never a part of the
conversation like it's always in and out
it's always Shake Shack but I always say
like five guys never is getting they
never get shine
they're trying but the in-and-out double
double is just [ __ ] good it's so good
and the peppers are good
there's the complexity right yeah yeah
the other Jew their biggest problems
they all kind of tasted the same zero
taxpayer like even the Shake Shack was
and that's like they're usually good
back it just tastes like a like a meaty
peanut butter bread yeah it's I swear to
God and this is not fixed no it's uh
like I've fought I fought like in the
favor of Shake Shack over it right yes
yes and yeah and if you ask me like it's
like on the average moment where we do
have to get a burger I would go to shake
shop right
but this pepper thing blows the [ __ ]
yellow C in and now for me it's like the
master's degree of secret menu items
it's like the one with where they're
actually doing everything a little
differently yeah everything's different
the mustard cooked meat yeah was [ __ ]
fantastic there you go I know you're
gonna [ __ ] again yeah
[Music]
sup guys have a Kyle out for the burger
show thank you for watching
hit the like button hit the subscribe
button if not for me for the burgers
please and thank you